Gracie McGraw has definitely inherited
her musical talents from her superstar
parents demographics you Instagram on
Monday posting a video of him and his
eldest daughter covering Barbra
Streisand and Barry Gibbs 1980s hit what
kind of fool because we all know the
best way to spend a road trip is with a
little karaoke
Oh
[Music]
sharing the performance clip with his
2.3 million followers the country star
writes pipes dang this girl can sing but
with parents of Tim and Faith Hill
clearly the apple doesn't fall far from
the tree
while filming the video Gracie takes
center stage and her dad backs her up
with the harmony
[Music]
but this is the first time the two have
teamed up for a collaboration back in
2015 Gracie joinder dad on stage in
Nashville to sing Tim Pitts here tonight
off his albums damn country music we
can't wait to see what this father and
daughter duo will bring next what would
you like to hear them sing let us know
in the comments below
[Music]